régis souper analyste géopolitique et
directeur exécutif d'interpol conseil
régis souper bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors en
2012 et en 2016 les deux par les deux
principaux candidats s'étaient déjà
affrontés c'est une campagne aux airs de
déjà vu avec ça exactement on va dire
c'est un tour de chauffe pour les deux
poules est proposé un poulet de les deux
candidats principaux ils se sont déjà
affrontées une première et la troisième
fois et le résultat leur évitant comme
on le dit sera très très serré mais pour
pour le pool électoral pour le peuple le
gall et quatre ghanéens c'est c'est
quasiment une réédition de l'exercice
qui connaissent déjà
alors un résultat très serré vous venez
de le dire en tout cas chômage
infrastructures éducation santé quels
sont les principaux enjeux de la
présidentielle ce justement qui que les
électeurs attendent particulièrement le
ghana date dans le paysage ouest
africain et est même si le continent
africain fait modèle c'est un modèle
c'est un côté à la fois démocratique et
politique
donc il ya deux catégories dans le jeu
il ya un enjeu qui est comparatif qui
est par rapport à la géopolitique locale
et qui dit la chose suivante c'est que
par rapport aux élections qui se sont
passées donc en guinée ou en côte
d'ivoire on a vu un contexte pré
électoral qui était vicié qui était
totalement sec écrit keith être et ds je
remets pas parfois et alors que le ghana
le ghana a fait a fait la preuve d'une
campagne d'une tempête au plus tôt
civilisé plus tôt puis plutôt plus plus
plus tôt police et entre en or entre les
principes et les principaux challengers
donc si vous voulez il ya d'abord un
enjeu comparatif par rapport à la
géopolitique du conduit de la région
ouest africaine maintenant au niveau
local au niveau intérieur ce qui
intéresse davantage plus laid l'ailé les
ghanéens
je pense que non dans les propos qui
sont assez souvent répertorié il
souhaite justement qui est lutte contre
la corruption et qui agit seulement un
retour de pour une bonne gouvernance
économique parce que c'est un pays
gangréné par une corruption économique
en même qui est qui
quelqu'un c'est incroyable donc y'a
comme il ya quand même ceux des vies
profonde et canet 1 à ce que justement
les deniers publics soient mieux gérées
donc il ya la commission il ya la lutte
contre la corruption bien sûr gala
questions liées à la santé et à
l'éducation
et puis j'ai un sujet qui qui a plutôt
est un bandit par l'opposant principal
qui est le sujet de la piraterie
maritime et de la sécurité intérieure
qui est un sujet très sympa faut pas
oublier le ghana qu'un pays côtiers donc
c'est aussi pas la piraterie maritime
doc est aussi des enjeux de sécurité
alors vous le rappeliez 1 le ghana sur
le continent africain est un exemple de
démocratie jusqu'ici le pays a toujours
les chapeaux violences post électorales
mais le président et son principal
opposant ont signé vendredi un pacte de
paix s'engageant à promouvoir aucune
violence
est ce que ça veut dire que les
candidats cette fois craignent des
affrontements suite aux résultats
je pense que c'est c'est une
particularité c'est une partie du car
était de gagner le contexte sous
régional
vous l'avez observé qu'ils sont en
guinée en côte d'ivoire et même dans
certains ont même dans certains pays où
il n'ya pas encore aujourd'hui des
élections mais plutôt des élections à
venir il ya quand même des qu'il ya
quand même un climat qui est assez
diffus et qui dit et qui dit la
complexité quand même des flexions des
élections sur le plan sous régional
les gagnants ont innové effectivement ce
pack de paix fait des mois qu'ils nerfs
qui n'inquiète tout sauf anecdotique
10la jeu suivant c'est que au soir au
soir dans que des élections le perdant
appellera le le perdant appellera le
vainqueur est en bonne et due forme lui
rendre les civilités et quelque part je
pense que c'est je pense que c'est ça le
prix vaches de rien du tout mais c'est
juste pour démontrer l'exemplarité de la
démocratie ghanéenne
alors on 28 ans le ghana a connu cette
élection cette élection pacifique vous
lui disiez un pays qui fait preuve
d'exemplarité
pourquoi pourquoi finalement ce pays
fait exemple en termes de démocratie
dans cette région
il faut dire faut dire c'est pas un pc
c'est une expérience en fait qu'il part
quand même deux
si vous voulez d'un historique est très
compliqué c'est un pays qui de 1966
jusqu'à 92 est un pays qui était à ces
menaces et il y avait plusieurs coups
d'état donc et il a fallu les personnes
politiques et l'entregent jeudi les
mains le leadership de l'ex président
jerry rawlings justement qui a qu'ici
vous voulez elle venue faire le ménage
il ya une nouvelle constitution en 92 et
et cette constitution elle est à fait
clair c'est une condition pour tout vous
dire qu'il n'a jamais été
qui n'a jamais été violée qui n'a jamais
été déplacée d'un poing ou d'une virgule
contrairement à l environnement régional
ou vous avez des constitutions qui sont
souvent battus en brèche qui sont
régulièrement contestés et qui permet
donc à des leaders qui sont souvent
qu'ils sont très contestables justement
de se représenter pour un troisième
mandat alors que la construction du le
le substrat même de la concession qui
gagne est interdite justement mais de
façon de façon absolue ce recours sur un
coupon un troisième mandat je pense que
les gars neyev aidez-moi je prie et
comme je le rappelais il y avait un
historique italie a eu plusieurs coups
d'état
il ya eu c'est un pays aussi bien connu
sa période sanglante
mais à partir de 92 grâce au leadership
de jerry rawlings qui a été cédée il ya
et il ya moins de deux mois
justement ce pays à retrouver si vous
voulez un peu la noblesse quand même de
l'existence l'éthique doit ce qui fait
que de l'avis de carnet de commandes
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on est quand même
dans un pays qui démontrait votre bd
démocratique merci beaucoup
régis pour votre analyse rappelle que
vous êtes analyste géopolitique et
directeur exécutif d'un père globe
conseil